SPEAKER 1: And we are
lucky, once in a while,
to welcome people like
Amy and Chef Donald
from Guittard Chocolates.
Amy is a fifth generation
chocolate manufacturer.
She is the great-great-great--
AMY GUITTARD: --great-great.
SPEAKER 1: --great-great
granddaughter
of Etienne Guittard, who came
from France during the Gold
Rush days, like many
of our forebears.
But when he saw how the
gold miners had the money
to buy good chocolate,
he went back to France
and learned about chocolate
and brought it back here.
And I would say for good
chocolate, like this,
I would pay almost
the price of gold.
So this is what you're
going to learn today.
And this is Guittard
Chocolate, not
the other chocolate
that begins with a G
that tourists flock
to, that has a kind
of Italian sounding name.
This is French.
And this is the chocolate
I love to cook with,
and it's so good to know that
it's American made and American
based.
So Chef, he's the
chef of Guittard.
He's based in Los Angeles and
teaches professionals, as well
as nonprofessionals, about
the ins and out of chocolate.
Amy has a book, where she
really writes about this.
She came back from
working with Cliff bars
to what she knew and
loved, which is chocolates.
And so I'm going to
hand it over to her.
Chocolate is an incredibly
deep and interesting subject.
I don't know if some of you
know that in the raw food
movement chocolate is
considered a super food.
It's got these incredible
antioxidants and list
of nutrients.
So that's your excuse, guys.
But keep it easy on the sugar.
And I also know that when I was
studying pastries and desserts
in France, that when
it came to chocolate,
we were handed a sheaf
of papers this thick.
You probably did,
I know you did.
And you're tested specifically
on your knowledge of chocolate
and temperatures
and how to handle it
and how finicky it can be.
So without much
ado, I'm very much
happy to have you
here and welcome,
and I'll hand this to you.
AMY GUITTARD: Thanks.
Thanks for the introduction.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all for coming.
I know you guys are
all super, super busy.
But we're stoked to
be here and to share
a little bit about
Guittard and also to dive
into the nuances of chocolate.
As alluded to earlier,
chocolate is super complex,
and there's a lot of
different ways and things
that you can dive
into when you're
starting to learn about it,
when you're baking with it.
And so what we did is we picked
two recipes from the book.
Donald has a chapter
in the back of it
that have a little bit
more sophisticated recipes.
So he's going to be
testing two of those today.
And we selected those
recipes primarily
because they showcase a
variety of different chocolates
that go into different
flavor nuances and also
different applications.
We've pulled a
selection of items.
We make probably, what, like
250 items maybe, more or less.
We have a collection,
Etienne line,
which is geared primarily to
professional pastry chefs.
A lot of those items are
also available for consumers,
but we pulled a
selection of those here,
which you guys can taste
after we do the demo.
And it's basically
just to showcase
the different
types of chocolate,
whether it's a chip,
a wafer, or a bar.
There's some fun stuff over
here between like a 70 and a 72,
which are seemingly
very close together
because the percentages
are the same,
but they couldn't
taste more different.
So I'm kind of
jumping ahead here,
but I wanted you guys to sort
of have that as a foundation
to help you navigate as we
talk through the recipes,
to know that there is this
sort of diversity of products
over here that you'll be able
to explore once we finish.
And as mentioned, I am
the fifth generation
of my family business,
which was started
in 1868 in San Francisco.
We were making chocolate in
the Bay Area that whole time.
When we first opened, we were
doing coffees, teas, and spices
in addition to chocolate,
because chocolate,
we often talk about
in the industry is
that it's a grinding business.
You start off with a bean.
You grind it down, and
you make a cocoa powder.
You can make ground
liquor, which
is sweetened chocolate,
which is then oftentimes
a base for a lot of recipes.
But it's a grinding business.
It wasn't until after the '06
earthquake in San Francisco,
which everyone's
probably familiar with,
where we consolidated down
just to making chocolate.
So we've been doing that
for a whole bunch of years.
And most of what we do at
Guittard is we make chocolate,
but we do it in a way
that sort of marries
a tradition of our business
and the tradition and heritage
of chocolate in general, because
it has such a rich history,
with innovation.
The industry, as everyone
probably here knows
is so highly
saturated right now.
There are all these
bean-to-bar guys.
And everyone has their own
way of making chocolate.
And so what we do is always
looking for different ways
that consumers are
engaging with chocolate,
new recipes that chefs are
coming out with-- that's
a really important
part of what Donald
does-- different ways
that we can make chocolate
in our factory.
And most importantly, we're
always looking for new beans,
and that's a really big part.
You can't talk about
making chocolate
without talking about
the raw ingredient.
It's not a great
photo, but I brought
some pamphlets that are over
here, you guys can look at.
But cocoa is a bean.
It's a fruit.
I always tell people that
I start eating chocolate
at like 9:00 AM
anyway, but you're
getting your fruits and
vegetables by eating a fruit.
But it starts off as a fruit.
It's a bean.
It's a seed, actually.
This is a dried cocoa pod, and
I'll leave this out for you
guys to look at.
It grows on a tree.
It grows 15 to 20 degrees
either side of the equator,
what we call the cocoa belt.
And we source beans from all
over the world.
We do single origins.
We do blends.
Each region has their own
sort of flavor profile, which
is also really important
to how you make chocolate
and what goes into
either creating a recipe
and selecting the chocolate.
What happens on the farm
level, the fermentation
and drying process, again
is really, really crucial
component to getting
the right flavor.
So it's not only the terroir.
It's not only the genetics
of the bean, like a Braeburn
versus a Pink lady versus
a Granny Smith apple.
You've got similar
types of things
with regards to a cocoa pod.
You have Trinitario,
Forastero, Criollo,
all sorts of different types.
So it's that.
But it's also what the farmer
does with the bean at origin
before it even comes to us.
And then we like to
say we try and listen
to how the being
wants to be roasted
and treated once we start
making chocolate from it.
And then it works its
way through our factory
and then gets in the hands
of chefs like Donald,
who then taste the
chocolate, figure out
sort of the nuanced flavors,
and then has an ability
to then craft a recipe
that can kind of celebrate
those flavors that really
starts on the farm,
goes through our factory,
and ends up in a kitchen.
So I'm going to hand
it over to Donald.
There will be time afterwards,
I believe, for questions.
And, yeah, so he's going to
do two recipes, as I said,
that showcase different
types of chocolates.
And I'll probably jump
in and ad lib as we go.
DONALD WRESSELL: Great.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
So we're going to start off with
making a chocolate pound cake.
It's a five-meal-a-day
kind of a recipe.
You can have it for breakfast,
lunch, tea, dinner, midnight
snack.
So I'm going to start
off with some butter.
What's critical about
all pound cakes, not just
chocolate pound cakes, is
that all the ingredients
are at room temperature
for the physics of mixing.
So I'm going to go ahead and add
sugar, a little bit of honey,
and butter to this.
It's going to get a
little noisy for a minute.
And I'm going to aerate this.
This is the creaming method
we talk about in baking.
So I'm going to
cream the butter.
I'm going to introduce
a lot of air cells
that are going to
improve the texture
or actually create the
texture for the cake.
We're also going to add
some egg and whip that in.
That's also going to
add some air to it.
And we're also going to
use just a little bit
of leavening, a little
tiny bit of baking powder.
So three ways I'm trying
to get cell structure
and lift for this pound cake
so it's not dense and heavy.
We are going to try
this today, by the way.
So while that's whipping,
going to give it about maybe 90
seconds to two minutes, I
have my dry ingredients here.
I need to sift those
together-- cocoa powder.
I'm using our Coco Rouge, which
is this is red can over here.
You have a look at it.
It's a 22%, 24%
fat cocoa powder,
which is kind of standard
for baking recipes.
So to incorporate, I'm just
sifting these ingredients--
salt. So sifting is to aerate.
It's also to incorporate
things, so I do it on paper.
A little finally mixing,
so that's ready to go.
I'm going to go ahead
and add in our eggs.
So these eggs are
room temperature.
SPEAKER 1: Chef, why is it
important to have ingredients
at room temperature?
DONALD WRESSELL:
Well, so first of all,
the butter will whip
up nice and light.
If I dump a cold egg onto that,
all of that air I put into it
is going to actually cause
the butter to chill down.
All my air is going to go away.
So right now I've got a light--
can you all see in there?
Is there a way to see in there?
Sort of?
How about if I do-- no.
No.
All right.
We'll leave it like that.
I'm going to stop
the bowl for a second
because it's almost
ready to go anyway.
That way you can
kind of see-- so it's
light and lemon-yellowish,
very important.
So, yeah, it's very light.
So I'm just going to give it
a little bit of a scrape here.
Fortunately, this
paddle attachment
we have in this mixer does a
really nice job of scraping,
so I don't even have
to do that much.
But you do want to scrape often.
But the machine has
really been helpful.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] butter?
DONALD WRESSELL: What's that?
This is sugar and butter and
a little bit of honey, yeah.
And so over here we've
got the all-purpose flour,
cocoa powder, a
little pinch of salt,
and tiny bit of baking powder.
And now we're going to add our
dry and our liquids together.
So I've got a little bit of
coffee and vanilla extract.
I've got some buttermilk.
And we're going to incorporate
the dry and the wets together.
You've probably
read recipes where
it says alternate dry and wet.
What's that all about?
So if I were to dump
all the liquids in,
the butter fat would
separate, wouldn't
be able to absorb this liquid.
If I put all the flour
in and kept mixing,
it would toughen
up our structure.
We wouldn't have
a nice light cake.
So that's why you
want to alternate.
So I'm going to start off
with a little bit of flour.
So I like to use this method
of getting stuff into the bowl.
It's a lot cleaner than
trying to use a spoon
or dump it out of a
scoop or something.
So a little bit of our dry,
a little splash of our wet.
AMY GUITTARD: Just a note
on that cocoa powder.
It's a Dutched cocoa powder.
You guys probably see on
shelves that they're sometimes
natural cocoa powders,
Dutched cocoa powder.
Dutched cocoa powder
is oftentimes something
that I describe as
like it has like
a Moorish, which is a funny--
it's like you want more of it.
It's like that
Oreo cookie flavor.
And it's processed
with-- it's like alkalis.
So it's sodium bicarbonate.
And so it gives it a very
different flavor note
than like a natural
cocoa powder,
and you've got to adjust your
recipe if you're using natural
in lieu of a Dutch, just because
it's got additives in there.
Right, Donald?
DONALD WRESSELL:
Yes, that's right.
And how you adjust that is
by adding some baking soda,
bicarbonate of soda.
So you change the pH
of the cocoa powder.
So a little bit more mixing.
I'm going to use my
final amount of dry.
So now our cake is
essentially mixed.
Off the machine.
And I'll do a little final
folding together here.
So now this is kind of
the-- when I set out
to make this recipe, I wanted to
create a cake that wasn't just
all cocoa powder
based, and I wanted
to add more chocolate flavor.
So what I did is
I grated our 91%,
which you can taste over
here, on a box grater--
just a simple box
grater like this.
And then I'm going
to fold this in.
So it'll be just another little
shot of chocolate in there.
So just, again, trying
to push the chocolate
flavor forward in the cake.
Sometimes you see pound cakes
that are really shiny and dark.
Those are always made with
oil and just cocoa powder.
But I wanted a true
chocolate flavor in here,
so we'll taste it later and you
can see what I'm talking about.
AMY GUITTARD: So
something that's
really important about
working with chocolate
is understanding
what percentage is.
And so like the
cocoa nib, which we
don't have any
here unfortunately,
do you have any in your recipes?
I can't remember.
DONALD WRESSELL: I do not today.
AMY GUITTARD: You don't.
So a cocoa nib is basically
the roasted cocoa bean
before it's ground down.
The cocoa nib is more or
less 50% fat, 50% solid.
And so when you're looking at
a percentage, percent cacao,
you can sort of
try and figure out
that the percentage is
representative of the cocoa
mass.
The remaining percentage
is typically sugar.
If it's a milk chocolate, it's
sugar and milk added to it.
You can kind of sort
of figure out from that
the difference between
the fats and the solids.
Sometimes you add
cocoa butter in,
which is the sign
of a couveture.
The 91 has added
cocoa butter in it.
If you don't add
cocoa butter, it's
going to be a different
sort of rheology.
So this 72% does not have
added cocoa butter in it.
So the fat content is more
or less-- what would that be?
30-- no, come on, Amy.
DONALD WRESSELL: It's
about 30-- about 35, yeah.
AMY GUITTARD: OK, thanks.
And then the 70 has
added cocoa butter in it.
So it's just something
to keep in mind as you're
working with chocolate.
And then I'll add onto that once
Donald goes through his next--
DONALD WRESSELL:
All right, so that's
what our batter looks like.
I got these cute little pans.
They're half pound loaf pans.
You can bake it in a bigger pan.
That's OK.
But these are so adorable,
I thought I would use those.
So getting this into the
pan without getting it
all of the table--
a couple of ways.
A scraper works.
I like an ice cream scoop.
That is really helpful.
You kind of drop it in.
We'll fill the pans of
about 2/3 of the way.
So I sprayed a little
bit of pan spray here,
or you can use butter.
SPEAKER 1: Well, what
was the question?
DONALD WRESSELL: Oh,
the question was, she's
asking, what's the difference
between spraying and using
parchment paper?
I use both.
So I want it coming out.
I don't want any chance
for it not to come out.
So I put a little
spray in there,
which attaches the paper
to the pan, actually,
and then push the paper in.
Now it stays.
And then we put a little spray
on top, so it just helps.
It could be butter also or oil.
So a couple methods of
getting it into the pan.
I'll just use this
little guy here just
to kind of smooth
them out a bit.
Give it a tap.
That will knock any
air cells that are
stuck in there, little pockets.
So those are ready to go.
I'm just going to lose
these over this way, please.
Thank you.
We're going to make a
little topping for it.
So it's done real quickly
in a food processor.
Move this out of the way.
Thank you.
So food processor-- so I've
got demerara sugar, which
is an unrefined brown sugar.
It's got a little more molasses
in it, cocoa powder again,
our Coco Rouge, some roasted
hazelnuts, all-purpose flour,
a little pinch of salt.
So what I'm going
to do is go ahead
and drop the sugar in here
first, cocoa powder, flour.
Whoops, made a
little mess there.
If I had used my
paper method, it
wouldn't be all
over the table now.
So I'm just going to combine
these ingredients together.
Now I'm going to go ahead
and pulse in these hazelnuts.
And roasting hazelnuts
twice is a practice
that I've always had.
Hazelnuts gain more flavor
by roasting them two times.
In a crumble like this situation
that's surrounded by fat,
all the moisture coming off the
cake, the hazelnuts won't cook,
so they'll be kind of rawish.
Break those guys up.
I think we'll start our
second recipe, which
is going to be a cookie.
It's the triple
chocolate cookie recipe.
Forgot that.
That's salt.
Triple chocolate cookies--
so I've melted chocolate.
There's two kinds of chocolate.
There's a 100% and
a 64% in butter.
So I'm melting chocolate.
I use a water bath occasionally.
I can also use a microwave.
You can melt the butter
separately from the chocolate,
combine the two.
You can melt them both together.
The point is getting them
melted and then homogeneous.
So we're just going to
stir these two together--
or these three things
together rather.
So there's 100%, 64, and
someone unsalted butter here.
I've got some eggs, sugar.
We're going to give
a little bit of air
to this, about one minute
of whipping at high speed.
AMY GUITTARD:
Donald, do you want
to talk a little
bit about how you
work with like new chocolates
and develop recipes
around new chocolates?
DONALD WRESSELL: Vanilla.
Yes, so when I get a new
chocolate from Guittard,
I'll taste it first
against a bunch of things
that I might have
in the kitchen.
I'll taste it with fruit.
I'll taste it with coffee.
I might just eat it
with some sour cream.
I just have a little panel of
different kinds of ingredients
in the kitchen and sort of see
what jumps out when I'm tasting
it-- passion fruit perhaps.
What else?
Nut products-- and
sort of see if there's
any inherent traits
in the chocolate
that kind of correspond nicely
with this particular chocolate.
So I'm always looking
for pairings that way.
And then I'll mess around
with the rheology of it.
I'll see how it melts.
I'll see how it
handles on the table.
Then I'll see how it
folds into ingredients,
just sort of check
it out that way.
And that's how I come
up with new things.
AMY GUITTARD: I think
when we sit around
the table at the office
and try and develop
new flavor profiles, it
usually starts with the beans
that we get.
We've got really strong
relationships with farmers
all over the world, and it's a
very word-of-mouth community.
So we'll get an email or a
phone call from a farmer.
They'll come up to
us at a trade show
and hand us a bag
of samples and say,
can you make
chocolate out of this?
And tell me what you think,
which is what we love to do.
And it's that dialogue and that
relationship with these farmers
that sort of leads
us to developing
a lot of these chocolates
that Donald is saying kind of
inspires him to develop
these new recipes.
And I think one of
the things when you're
baking with chocolate is getting
familiar with the different
flavor profiles and allowing
yourself sort of the freedom.
A lot of the recipes
in our cookbook
are basic enough that
you can be like, OK,
so now I know how to make a
regular old chocolate chip
cookie.
Let me switch it up
a little bit maybe
use a single origin,
Madagascar, because I
know it's got some
cranberry notes in it,
and I want to toss in some
dried cranberries in that
and spruce it up a little.
So having that sort of language
and being comfortable enough
to be able to do
that in the kitchen
comes with sort of
understanding a flavor.
DONALD WRESSELL: Exactly.
So I'm going to just sift this
flour and a little bit of salt
together again for this recipe.
Also make it easy
to get in there.
So we'll put this on
hold for just a minute.
So our three components
for the cookie
is the melted chocolate/butter
mixture, our aerated eggs
and sugar, and then our flour.
OK
Now I'm going to cut this
butter up into little cubes.
SPEAKER 1: Chef, do you
prefer a special butter?
DONALD WRESSELL: I like
and unsalted butter
in all my recipes.
Usually, it's like 82%.
It can be a little lower.
So I'm just going to
pulse these guys together.
SPEAKER 1: 82% fat?
DONALD WRESSELL: 82% fat, yeah.
That's kind of European style.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DONALD WRESSELL:
Cold butter, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DONALD WRESSELL: Yes,
if I used soft butter,
it would kind of be a
greasy sort of consistency.
And we definitely don't
want that for streusel.
SPEAKER 1: So you're looking
for a course, crumbly mixture?
DONALD WRESSELL:
Course, crumbly-- I
should be able to
grab it with my hand,
and it'll clump together.
AMY GUITTARD: It's like,
what are you doing to me?
DONALD WRESSELL: What
am I doing to it?
There's a piece of butter trying
to get down in the bottom.
We'll get it down in there.
We're going to push
it down actually.
There we go.
All right.
Perfect.
We're going to massage
it into his bag here.
I do this in a piece of paper.
So, as you can see, it
kind of sticks together.
So I'll just mix a
little bit by hand here.
We'll put some into this bag.
Now you can use it
this way straight away,
but I'm just going to show
you a quick technique.
Well, let's just
do one this way.
So here's our crumble
topping-- easy way.
I'll show you a different way,
an alternative way to do it.
I press it into
a sheet, like so.
Then I refrigerate it,
keep it ready to go.
Get that out of the way.
And then it is kind of ready.
I keep a lot of doughs
this way-- prepared.
They're sealed.
AUDIENCE: Do you freeze it?
DONALD WRESSELL:
I freeze it, yeah.
I can freeze it
or refrigerate it.
And then what I'm
going to do is just
going to press it
through a screen,
and I can create a
little crumb this way.
Get rid of that.
Thank you.
And then you can
just kind of press it
through, either with a rolling
pin or even with your hand.
And it wasn't cold enough--
our little make-shift fridge.
But anyway, you can
present through,
and you end up with
these nice little uniform
crumbs like that.
SPEAKER 1: Chef, this is
assuming you have leftovers,
right?
DONALD WRESSELL: Assuming you
have leftovers-- assuming.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
Not in my kitchen.
No, there wouldn't be.
DONALD WRESSELL:
All right, so we're
going to use a few of these
just for a cake, our other cake.
But they're kind of a
uniform little crumbs.
SPEAKER 1: That's beautiful.
DONALD WRESSELL:
So those are going
to go in the oven right down
here, 350 about 30 minutes.
I say about it
because all ovens tend
to be a little bit different.
So we'll watch 30
minutes on that.
You timing that?
All right, so back
to the cookie.
So again, review, so our
butter and chocolate mixture
is going to go right into
this egg-sugar emulsion.
There we go.
Fold that together.
Followed by our dry mix.
And I'm going to fold in some
milk chocolate wafers, hence
the triple chocolate.
AMY GUITTARD: Is that the 38%?
DONALD WRESSELL: That's the 38%.
So in here it's the 100%,
the 64, and this 38% milk.
And then I'm going to pour
it onto this sheet pan
and chill it.
And then if you take a piece
of paper and just fold this up,
spread it out a little bit, and
now you've got a top for it.
So now it's
completely sealed, so
in the refrigerator that
goes till it's cold,
maybe half hour, maybe longer.
Or it could be tomorrow.
Then what that looks like
when it's all done is this.
So it's chilled dough now.
And what I'm going
for is to end up
with something that looks
like this in the end.
So these are kind
of ready to go.
So it's a stick of cookie
dough, and now there's
the paper that we're going to
bake it on, so it's not wasted.
Thank you.
A little flour on the board.
So this is how I'm going to
up with this particular piece.
The paper goes away.
A little bit of flour.
I'll just cut them into bars.
Add this one in, just if
you have any empty spaces.
So I give it a little squeeze.
Get the shape started.
And that's how that works.
So on the paper it goes.
We wrap it up and roll it.
So now you've got the
cookie, which you can freeze,
you can refrigerate--
refrigerate a couple of weeks,
freeze couple of months.
Nice to have them on hand.
Any questions
about that process?
It's kind of simple.
SPEAKER 1: Chef, thank you.
I always forget how much
work it is to make pastries.
This is why I'm no
longer in pastries.
Are there any questions?
DONALD WRESSELL:
Oh, no, it's easy.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
DONALD WRESSELL: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: Are we going to
get a taste of everything now?
DONALD WRESSELL: We are.
There are pound
cakes over there.
Everyone's got a plate.
Is that what it is?
Should we taste it
now, do you think?
SPEAKER 1: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What is the
advantage of like using 100
and then 64 as supposed to
something in the middle?
DONALD WRESSELL: So this
is a really intensive
flavored cookie.
So I'm using the 100%.
I'm controlling
the amount of sugar
that goes along with that.
Because like in the 64%, 36%
of that's going to be sugar.
So I've added a blend
of these chocolates
together just to kind of
create this nice strong flavor
that you're going to
taste in a minute.
If I had used chocolate that
had sugar already in it,
it would be really sweet
and kind of cloying
and not dark and rich,
like this cookie is.
SPEAKER 1: So you're really
controlling the taste of effect
that you want.
DONALD WRESSELL: Yes, I'm
controlling the taste effect.
I'm controlling the flavors.
I'm blending two
kinds of chocolate
together and then
adding an inclusion,
which is milk chocolate.
So coming back to the
inclusion, so let's say
you don't want to put
milk chocolate in,
that inclusion part that
I folded in at the end,
it could be anything.
It could be white chocolate.
It could be dark chocolate.
It could be milk chocolate.
It could be nuts,
if you wanted to.
The base cookie recipe that
you'll find in the book
is what you need to create this.
Anyway, the inclusions
can be up to you.
You can be creative about that.
SPEAKER 1: This is amazing.
It's in the book, right?
DONALD WRESSELL:
It is in the book.
SPEAKER 1: Recipes
are in the book.
How's the chocolate tasting?
So we can ask more technical
questions about how to make.
But I wanted to ask Amy,
you're the generation
who's brought sustainability
back into your business.
And you were talking so lovingly
and knowingly about the farmers
that you deal with.
Do you want to tell
us what you've done
and why the cacao growing
and sustainability
is making such a difference?
AMY GUITTARD: Yeah,
I mean, I think
I wouldn't go as far as to say
that I brought sustainability
to Guittard.
Because one of the things that
was so humbling about coming
to the family business after
not working there for a while
was sort of realizing
that all the stuff
we've done without
really talking about it.
My grandfather used
to go to origin,
and relationships is such a
crucial part of what we do,
and really realizing that
that was just inherently
how we do business,
which was pretty awesome
and humbling, again.
So what we have been doing is
working to try and articulate
what those relationships
mean and what they look like.
We go to origin.
I go to origin all the time with
our director of sustainability,
as does my dad.
And one of the sort of pivotal
points of what we do at origin
is talking to
farmers about flavor.
You'll oftentimes hear
how important yields
are, how you've got
farmers need more cocoa.
Because with more cocoa,
they can get more money.
But what you don't
realize is that you also
have to take into account
what the flavor is.
Because with just a
constant onslaught
of high-yielding
plants, it's oftentimes
at the detriment of flavor.
And you don't have this
beautiful, nuanced, balanced
flavor that's so important to
making good chocolate, which
is also important to creating
a sustainable supply chain.
I think we so oftentimes
think about sustainability
in terms of programs on the
ground or things like that.
But it's also about putting
in place systems that
create for long-term success
and longevity for a product.
So we talk about flavor.
We talk about relationships.
We do a lot of programs
on the ground-- women's
empowerment stuff, helping
towards child protection
initiatives in
West Africa, which
is a really big, very
challenging cultural thing that
happens over there.
SPEAKER 1: Do you
want to give us
a quick guide to how to taste
the chocolate you've put out,
what the origins are?
AMY GUITTARD: Sure,
yeah, we didn't
bring our single origins,
which in hindsight would have
been fun for you guys to taste.
But maybe I'll send
them down, and you guys
can do a sampling
at another time.
But we selected the
products that Donald
is using in his recipes
because it's fun,
and I totally nerd
out about this stuff.
But it's fun to taste the
chocolate as itself and sort
of close your eyes and
envision, sort of as Donald
was talking about,
what he does when he
is trying to develop a recipe.
Taste the chocolate, and
then if you haven't already
finished your plates, which it
looks like most of you have,
try and taste the chocolate
against the finished dessert.
But I pulled the 70 in
the 72, neither of which
are included in the recipes.
But again, it's just a
fun point of comparison.
The 72 isn't an origin.
It's a blend.
Both of those are blends.
The 70 is a little bit more of
a French style, a little bit
more peaky, fruity.
The 72 is what, again,
we call Moorish.
You kind of want more of it.
There's like sipping
chocolates, which are oftentimes
more of the single
origins, where you can only
take a little bit,
and it's to savor it.
And then the Moorish sometimes,
it's more of a Dutched note.
But the 72 doesn't have
any Dutching in it.
But it's made primarily from
beans out of West Africa, which
has a very coconutty flavor.
So when you taste
them side by side,
you'll be able to
pick up on that.
I also pulled the 38 and
the 45, both of which
are milk chocolates, but again,
total different opposites
of the spectrum.
The 38 is more of a fresh dairy
note, more of an American style
milk chocolate.
The 45 has more of like
a sour dairy note to it,
so it's a little bit more
of like a French style.
And then we have 63% chip.
And we didn't quite
get to this, but when
you guys are baking, if you're
looking through the cookbook,
you'll see that there's
some recipes that
call for wafers, some that
call for baking chips.
The easiest way that I can sort
of describe the difference--
you can make a chocolate chip
cookie with both-- is a baking
chip oftentimes serves as like
an architectural structure.
It's got less
cocoa butter in it,
so it's going to
hold up your cookie.
Whereas if you bake a
cookie with baking wafers,
there's more cocoa butter in it.
That's why it's flatter.
So when you bake
a cookie with it,
it's going to be like a little
bit of a flatter cookie.
It's going to be a
little bit oozier.
So I put that out
there just for fun,
not that you don't know what
a baking chip looks like.
But it's there.
And then 100%, if you're
daring, go for it.
It's super palatable for 100%.
It doesn't have any sugar
in it-- the original energy
bar, as I like to say.
The 91 and then the 64, and then
we have the Cocoa Rouge out,
just so you can see that really
beautiful red color, which
comes from the beans.
And that's a Dutched
powder as well.
SPEAKER 1: Donald, do you have
a favorite-- a cook's point
of view about what
they're going to taste?
DONALD WRESSELL: Gosh,
that's a hard question
because I use so many of them
for so many different reasons.
Again, I like to blend them.
I like to blend chocolates.
SPEAKER 1: So you used
the 100% and the 60--
DONALD WRESSELL: 64 and
the 38 in that cookie.
I used Coco Rouge and the
91% in the pound cake.
SPEAKER 1: Really interesting.
DONALD WRESSELL: Yeah,
I like to combine them.
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
AUDIENCE: Hi, a
question about fondue.
Of all the ones that you just
described, which ones would
you recommend the
most if somebody wants
to make a chocolate fondue?
DONALD WRESSELL: A
chocolate fondue?
AUDIENCE: With fruits
like strawberries in it.
DONALD WRESSELL: Well,
chocolate fondue,
are you talking about
mixing it with cream
or just straight chocolate?
Just straight chocolate?
I think I would use
the 70% over there.
Yeah, I would.
SPEAKER 1: I would
mix it with cream.
DONALD WRESSELL: She
would mix it with cream.
But also, yeah-- also good.
AUDIENCE: I was just
curious, in your pamphlet
it says that you work
with governments to help
with the right of
the chocolate makers.
How does that
relationship look like?
DONALD WRESSELL: So governments,
in terms of local governments
at origin-- so cocoa is
one of the biggest sort
of commodities for a
lot of these countries
that are growing it.
And the government oftentimes
regulates the price
and regulate sort of the
inputs that they get,
whether it's fertilizers,
planning materials, things
like that.
It's heavily, heavily
regulated, which
is a good thing because
a lot of these farmers
are living out in
the boonies, and they
don't have access to things.
A lot of the roads
are really bad.
So when the government's
involved, it's good,
but it's oftentimes
when you work
in collaboration with them, it
sort of affords an opportunity
for different sorts of
perspectives to be shared
and understood.
For instance,
flavor is something
that they don't
necessarily realize.
There's a disconnect between
the importance of flavor
and how that impacts
price on the cocoas traded
on the futures market.
So it impacts price.
It impacts sort of the long term
perspective of the cocoa plant
itself.
And so that's just
one example of how
working in collaboration
with government
sort of brings additional
perspective about how they can
aid farmers and
sort of-- for us,
it's more about
capacity building.
So with knowledge and
with that sort of dialogue
can create sort of long
term success that's
owned by the
countries themselves,
rather than just coming in and
saying like, oh, plant this.
One of the things that we do in
Ghana is we have flavor labs.
That's in conjunction with
the Cocoa Research Institute
of Ghana, CRIG, which they
have huge resources available.
And so we instituted
a flavor lab there
to give them the tools so
they know how to taste.
So the planning materials
that they're getting in,
they can figure out whether it's
something that they actually
want to plant and hand
out to farmers, rather
than just knowing that
it's a high-yielding plant.
They came to our office,
a bunch of scientists--
Ghanaian scientists came to our
office and spent like a week
with us in our lab,
learning how to taste,
which is continued from all the
work that they've been doing.
And that's a USAID
program that we do.
We're doing a similar
thing in Indonesia
because they have a really
beautiful cocoa bean that
is, not to belabor it,
but in Indonesia they
harvest during the rainy season.
So when they're
drying in the sun,
the beans oftentimes
get too much moisture.
And so they'll dry
them near a fire,
which gives a smoky flavor,
which is not good for cocoa.
So if you guys see
a bar that says
like the inherent smoky
notes of a cocoa bean,
that's them trying to hide the
fact that they're getting beans
that are tainted with smoke.
Because you don't want
smoke in your beans.
But anyway, so we're working
with Indonesian government
to sort of implement a
similar program in Ghana--
to what we did in Ghana.
AUDIENCE: So Chef [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned that chocolate
seen as like a super food.
Have you seen any
changes in recent years
with market interests
or customer demand
for like products as the
whole raw food revolution
everything has been occurring?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I mean,
I think the trends in food
is that there's
always this sort of
like how can we eat delicacies
and like indulgent foods
and feel OK about it.
And I think the truth around
the antioxidants things
is that, yes, chocolate has
like inherent properties that
are good for you.
In terms of like new
trends and things
like that, not so much
by way of antioxidants.
I mean, I think you can look
at it at the marketplace
and you'll see that
there's an increased
interest in like raw foods.
I get really nervous
about raw cacao.
I mean I'll eat nibs, and
I eat stuff on the farm.
But I think that might just
because my stomach's somewhat
tough, knock on wood.
But the raw chocolate
movement, ugh, it's
like a little concerning
to me because there's so
many just icky things in
the bean that comes out
when you're roasting it.
But I think the
biggest trend that I
see right now is organic, at
least in the chocolate space.
I don't know how
you feel about that,
since you see it from a
different side of things.
DONALD WRESSELL:
Yeah, if I can just
circle back on the raw
chocolate thing just real quick.
AMY GUITTARD: Oh, yeah.
DONALD WRESSELL:
So cacao is heaped
in one-meter square
boxes, generally speaking,
and fermented.
So it's in the jungle area.
Then it's dried on a
concrete patio in the sun,
and then it's put
into a burlap bag.
And then it gets to
the factory, where
it could have foreign object,
like rocks and things in it,
whatever.
So we spend a lot of time
cleaning it before we put it
through the machinery.
So if you can imagine it
being heaped and fermented
and then dried on
a concrete patio,
the pathogen level can
be quite substantial.
So when you just pop cocoa
beans in your mouth raw,
I don't know, maybe--
I don't do it.
I won't do it.
You're tough.
I would never do that.
AMY GUITTARD: Well, no, I've
had my fair share of challenges.
DONALD WRESSELL:
So I just wanted
to explain how that
happens and how that looks.
And as Amy said, a lot of what
we get in the bean quality
has to do with what
happens at the farm.
And the fermentation and
drying process are critical.
AMY GUITTARD: Huge.
DONALD WRESSELL: Without
that being done correctly,
the beans don't have a chance.
AMY GUITTARD: I mean, that's
another thing we do at origin
is work with farmers.
We'll have them send us beans.
I mean, I just came
back from-- anyway,
I go to a bunch of
trade shows, and I'll
like bring beans back for me.
I'm like this came
from Cameroon,
and we'll do a test
run of the beans.
And if we can taste
it that they've
been improperly fermented, which
isn't necessarily a government
thing, but if they've
been improperly fermented
or not dried
properly, we'll give
that feedback to the farmers
and allow them to have,
again, a dialogue and kind of
get them on the right path,
because it's such a
crucial component.
A lot of these farmers
are super impoverished.
So this is their life savings.
And it's pretty cool.
SPEAKER 1: Will you talk
us through the anatomy
of the bean?
AMY GUITTARD: The anatomy
of the bean, the pod?
SPEAKER 1: So what is
actually crushed and made
into cacao paste?
AMY GUITTARD: So these
little white seeds,
which I'll leave this out here,
these are cocoa beans-- seeds.
They become-- everyone kind of
gets tripped up on the lexicon.
But these are seeds,
otherwise known as cacao.
We call it cocoa beans
once they come to us,
once they are just about
to go through the process.
But this white pulp is
what they ferment in,
and this is really crucial.
Different beans have
different fat content.
So like Ecuador tends
to have a little bit
of a lower fat content
than, say, like Madagascar
or something.
And that's just the
varietal of that's
grown in these different
countries of origin.
And that doesn't necessarily
impact the fermentation,
but it impacts the end product
when we're making chocolate,
because you're grinding it, as
I said when we first started.
So this white pulp is
what it kind of sits in,
as Donald said.
Different countries
ferment in different ways.
West Africa typically
does heap fermentation.
So they'll chop the
pod off the tree trunk.
Then they'll slice it open.
They'll pull the seeds out.
There's a really
quick period of time
before it starts to oxidize, so
you throw it into a, as I said,
in West Africa they
do heap fermentation.
So it's a science that
they've mastered, typically
passed down for generations.
They'll put the beans in a heap.
And then over the course
of two to three days,
they'll turn them
in on themselves.
It's actually like five to
seven days, more or less,
when they're fermenting.
And then in South
America they do
what we call box fermentation.
So it's cascading boxes.
They'll start off at the top.
Then-- super ingenious-- they
open the front of the box.
The fermented beans kind
of turn in on themselves,
and then they sit.
They put banana leaves on top.
Then they sit in that box.
Then a day later they open
it, and then they turn it.
And you'll sometimes see on a
farm like a little chalkboard,
where they'll start checking
off how many days, what it is.
These guys you know
their beans so well,
they can put their hand
in and feel the heat.
I'm still learning.
You can also tell whether
it's been properly dried
by the crunch of the
shell on the seed.
So that white pulp is
what it ferments in.
But then there's also,
like most seeds-- like
if you guys an apple,
you know the brown husk
sort of like comes
off, and you've
got that slippery
white seed inside?
That's kind of what I
could say is like the shell
of like a cocoa seed.
And then after it's fermented,
then you lay it out to dry,
typically at a solar dryer.
And so that's sort of
how that process works.
And then we get it at factory.
SPEAKER 1: And you are
roasting it in south city?
AMY GUITTARD: We're
based in Burlingame.
So we had to move down
there in like 1950
is when they decided to build
a freeway over our factory.
But we roast and make--
most of our chocolate
is sold on the wholesale side.
So you don't really
realize you're eating it.
But you're probably
eating more Guittard
than you might realize.
But it's sold in
as an ingredient,
and then we also have consumer
line, which is out here.
And then a lot of pastry
chefs use us as well.
AUDIENCE: I've read
projections that growing demand
for chocolate is starting
to outstrip supply
at a rather rapid rate
on international markets.
Is there any comment
that you have on that?
AMY GUITTARD: Yeah, I mean,
it's principles of economics--
supply and demand.
You know, I think you have
to remember that cocoa
is a commodity, and it's an
agricultural product at the-- I
don't want to say mercy.
But it fluctuates,
production fluctuates,
based on mother nature.
We just had an El
Nino season, which
typically means that
Africa's really, really dry.
South America is
really, really wet.
And those extremes-- cocoa's
a really delicate tree,
which is why there's so much
conversation around yields
and planting material,
and how can you
start planting more
robust trees that can last
longer in this extreme weather.
We always believe the
principles of economics
will sort of iron things out.
It's always been the case.
You look at the cocoa
market, and it's constantly
fluctuating.
So I think we'll have plenty of
chocolate to go around for all.
SPEAKER 1: What is the addictive
ingredient in chocolate?
What would you say it is?
AMY GUITTARD: Could you
answer that question?
Is it the theobromine?
DONALD WRESSELL: Well,
theobromine, apparently-- it's
a trace, trace, trace
amount of caffeine in there.
But that's not really
why people-- there's
something about chocolate
that creates a sensation
that you're in love.
Like it releases sort of--
SPEAKER 1: Phenylalanine?
DONALD WRESSELL: Yeah, exactly.
What you said, yeah.
AMY GUITTARD: And we also talk
about like taste has memory.
That's one of the things.
We also have this concept of
incremental degradation, which
is my dad should trademark
because he talks about it all
the time.
But it's the idea where the
things that you love, slowly
over time, start to
change flavor if you
don't keep track of what it is.
And we're talking about the
importance of keeping flavor
in mind when you're looking
at planning material
that's going in on the farms.
The same thing happens when
you're crafting chocolate.
You could be like,
uh, I'm not going
to add this bean today because
how we have to do this.
Over time, if you
continue to do that, it'll
incremental degradation,
the base of the chocolate's
going to change.
And that idea of
taste having memory--
that chocolate that you had when
you were a kid, if you taste
that 10 years later,
15 years later,
it's going to bring you
back to that moment when
you had that first chocolate.
And a lot of the
stuff that we do,
we've had in our
repertoire for 150 years,
and other stuff is really new.
And there's products
that I smell or taste,
and I'm just brought
right back to that moment
right then and there.
So, yeah, whether theobromine
or your soul I think that it's--
SPEAKER 1: Where do we go
to get a retail Guittard?
AMY GUITTARD: Yeah, so
you can buy our stuff.
Most premium supermarkets
light Draegers,
Mollie Stone's, Whole
Foods carries it.
Some of these items
are pretty new.
So I always say
ask your retailers,
because they may
not be aware of it
or it might just be on its way.
SPEAKER 1: Can you
can order online?
AMY GUITTARD: You can, limited
amount, and the shipping cost
is obscene because it's
a delicate product.
TBD.
SPEAKER 1: Can we please
have the cake come out?
DONALD WRESSELL: It's
just almost there.
So the thing about
cakes-- let me just
talk about cake real quick.
So if you slam the
door on a cake--
when the cake first
starts to bake,
it's just basically air cells
holding up the structure
until the proteins and
the starches coagulate,
if you will, or set.
So if you open the door and
shut it, the cake will collapse.
Have any of you ever
seen that before in cake?
Has it ever happened to anybody?
Raise a hand?
Yeah, so it's because
it's not set yet.
So this is where we are here.
It's just about there.
If I take it out
now, we're going
to have a little
cave-in in middle.
So how do I tell it's done?
The spring back actually.
It's just like pushing
on your forearm.
It springs back.
AUDIENCE: I usually
use a toothpick.
DONALD WRESSELL: Toothpick's OK.
That'll check moisture content.
If it's real wet
inside, it's not
going to be-- I'm so familiar
with doing that, I just
touch it with my hand
and I kind of know.
In time, it comes.
You bake enough
cakes, it'll happen.
Checking the temperature
with a thermometer
to see if it's done, is
that what you're asking?
You can.
I never do that.
I do that with other
things, but not with cake.
Really, it's just about the
feel of it, how it feels.
And actually, if you
want to, you come by
and just touch it when
I put it on the table.
And you can see kind of how
it feels, if that helps.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you both so much
for just a delicious afternoon.
AMY GUITTARD: Thanks
for having us.